aux abords de la ville de darkmouth
ces soldats Ukrainiens tirent sans
relâche des dizaines d'obus toute la
journée ils visent les troupes russes
situés à 500 mètres de leur position
notre objectif aujourd'hui d'empêcher
l'encerclement de barque
est utilisé pour empêcher l'ennemi
d'encercler la ville complètement
nous avons perdu notre commandant un
héros de l'Ukraine qui a consacré toute
sa vie à la résistance contre les
envahisseurs russes
malgré leur pugnacité les forces
ukrainiennes reculent le groupe Wagner a
revendiqué mercredi la prise de la
partie Est de darkmouth
sur la route de châssivia à l'ouest la
seule encore tenue par les Ukrainiens
ces soldats montent au front assis sur
ce blindé il s'échange un sourire avant
d'être envoyé dans la bataille
nous ne savons pas où nous allons
exactement ces confidentiels nous les
soldats de l'infanterie on est informé
juste avant de bouger
c'est une question de sécurité c'est
normal
il est déjà arrivé qu'un soldat appelle
sa femme et que l'ennemi écoute
je pense donc que c'est bien de ne pas
savoir où nous allons
la bataille de darkmouth et la plus
longue et la plus meurtrière depuis le
début de l'invasion russe si son intérêt
stratégique est aujourd'hui contestée
elle est devenue un symbole dans la
guerre au vu des lourdes pertes subies
par les deux camps